key point of distinction number two what
is the attitude that
physicists have and you studying physics
have two equations
and the answer is you just use them
right you get given equations you just
use them right i would say
you use them as appropriate i mean
you've got to work out what is the
appropriate equation i was having a look
at your physics data and formula sheet
the other day and essentially all you
need to do when i say use them
is you're going to have some values and
you will do one of two things or
sometimes both
you're going to substitute those values
into the appropriate formula
that's the first thing and then secondly
like
it has to be something that you could do
from the end of year 10 maybe a bit of
rearrangement right
make the change the subject to whatever
it is that you are trying to solve
and that's the extent of it in year 11
and 12 physics it has to be because we
can't assume that you actually have
taken
mathematics in years 11 and 12.
so for instance uh what's that one i
think it's an s right
s equals displacement equals
u t plus half a t squared right
now why is that true where does it come
from if i'm a physicist
don't care right i can just use it i can
just use it i don't need to know
i don't need any foundation for it i can
just go ahead quote it and use it as
appropriate
but that rather doesn't cut it in
mathematics right
for every equation that you're going to
use you need to be able to get where
that comes from from first
principles we have a name for that we
call it deriving
right uh not to be confused with
differentiation right i'm talking about
getting something
from excuse me it's theoretical
basis right so we would call that from
first
principles now just so it turns out this
equation
on the left hand side for displacement
it's not hard to derive
at all um it just takes some fairly
basic calculus that you already
know for example we would say by
definition
what is velocity it's a derivative right
what's what's it comparing what two
things is it comparing
it's displacement and time right change
in displacement
compared to oops that's a very messy s
change in displacement
compared to change in time right so from
this i could make a very
minor rearrangement and i can say look
let's just consider these two variables
separately our displacement one and our
time one
okay now again by definition i can say
what's velocity
i can think about that from an initial
condition plus whatever changes from
acceleration
based on how long you've changed that
right so we again have this familiar
equation in here
u initial velocity
plus acceleration times however long
that acceleration has been happening
time right with respect to t now there's
only one last piece of the puzzle here
which in physics we don't need to worry
about but in mathematics
we do how do i get from this statement
which is about the changes in
displacement the changes in time
to a concrete statement about the
displacement in time themselves
and the answer is we integrate right now
in this specific spot
you would integrate not just with
respect to displacement but you'd say
well let's integrate
from some point to another do you
remember us trying to work out a
constant integration
in this particular way if i have a
displacement initially of 0 begin at the
origin
then i can say sorry that's not meant to
be a t it's meant to be an s
i can say from naught to t
doing this integration it is very
straightforward to see from a calculus
point of view
where that half a t squared comes from
it comes from us doing
the power rule for integration right in
mathematics we care about that in
physics you don't need to you can just
quit it use as appropriate make sense
okay now i said motion is a big umbrella
term
and the two parts of it that we really
care about we should distinguish between
called kinematics and mechanics
mechanics being the part that we're
going to focus on okay
what does kinematics mean well it
actually has to do with the name
kinematics we say oh i'm going to the
cinema
to watch a movie right cinema is short
for
cinematograph which just means moving
picture moving picture literally right
so the
cinema in kinematics just means movement
and it's a question of if you've got a
thing
how's it moving can you describe how it
is moving for me
right now from a physics point of view
and this is mentioned right at the top
with
experimentation what do we do well you
just look at stuff right oops wrong
color
you observe it that's our fancy name for
look at stuff
and then you take measurements and if
you do that reliably enough you can
get a sense of how something is moving
but in mathematics observations
empirical data that's not actually what
we go off right we want to go off
of equations so things like say
displacement
help me out here what's the next one
when you differentiate you get
velocity you differentiate again you get
acceleration all these things
oh yeah we can understand through just
look at the previous row right
we can understand these from the point
of view of their equations via
calculus we're going to differentiate
and integrate to go back and forth
do you see this we don't have an
accelerometer
measuring acceleration we have equations
of acceleration right so we're not
taking data points we're using the
equations
and then going back and forth by
calculus
okay now we're finally getting to the
point right at mechanics
mechanics is more than just how does it
move it's asking a deeper question
which is why why why is it doing that
what are the reasons for it why
does it move like that i'll do you one
better
why is gamora anyway um i
i have all this like second guessing now
cause i'm like what movies have you even
watched anyway i have to
i don't know anymore now in physics
again thanks to this guy
right we basically take his three laws
and just like with the equations we just
say
do i need to know where they come from
no don't need to know why no
we just take them and use them okay and
you can do a lot with that right
now those three laws i don't know about
you but i remember them this way i
remember them by their names right
the first law is the one about inertia
right that taylor swift loves to sing
about hate is gonna hate
heartbreak is gonna break whatever it is
the rest of that song right
things are gonna keep doing whatever it
is that they are currently
doing whether that's staying still or in
motion right
that's the first law second law is the
one that relates
force and momentum right it has to do
with
the change the rate of change of
momentum
being directly proportional and in the
same direction as whatever force you're
applying
right and then lastly third law
actual reaction action reaction right
you might call it the law of opposition
but action reaction is
a pretty memorable way to do it now once
you've got these set up and you can
assume them
you can send human beings to the moon
with that stuff this is powerful but in
mathematics
we actually want to dig into the why
even further right so what we do is we
create what we call a mathematical
model what do we use to go into our
model and the answer is
we model the direction and the magnitude
or the directions and magnitudes i
should say
uh by the way what topic tells us about
direction magnitude
vectors right so weirdly vectors was not
in
um the course for years and years and
years officially anyway
but we talked about direction and
magnitude we just never called them
vectors right it's a bit like um
he who must not be named so it's that
kind of thing right we though we have
the formal language of vectors
what are we modeling the vectors of and
the answer is
uh going back to this idea of forces but
more specifically i'm going to give
examples in a second
forces and the masses of the objects
that we're having a look at so one of
the key differences
that you'll see in mechanics questions
in extension 2 as compared to any other
motion you're looking at in advance or
extension 1 is
will tell you how much things weigh and
then expect you to make calculations on
the basis of that
right so just real quick before we leave
off because i put like forces
up here as a thing in quote marks that
physics is interested in that matt is
not interested in but now when i say
forces down here
what am i referring to let's have a look
at some of the easy ones right so for
example
the most common one you're going to deal
with is gravity though i know we could
have an argument about whether gravity
is a force or not so let's just put
weight there
as well just for good measure yeah i i
won't get started into that argument too
too deep rabbit hole right um when you
throw something
and then you let go right what's that
called starts with a p
that's called projection right when you
project something off
into the air uh that again introduces a
force into something that makes it move
what about if you had something which
wasn't just thrown but it had the
ability to
push itself along as it went what would
you call that starts with the teeth
that's thrust right
so if you for example had a rocket or a
plane
it's not just pushed off and then off it
goes actually it continues pushing
itself right
often the reason why it needs to
continue pushing itself is because
something is trying to stop it
right so we would call that things that
are trying to stop your motion
resistance and
the two that you're probably going to be
most frequently encountering are
when you are rubbing against a surface
so we call that friction
um or when you are hitting you know
uh particles of a gas that your fluid
that you're flying through
which we call drag now it's probably
worth
just mentioning just to make you feel a
little bit better because your brain is
like
gradually getting like fuller and fuller
at this point i'm going to give you one
thing that you no longer need to worry
about now that you're in the new course
and it's something called talk
does anyone know what talk is someone
describe what talk is
talk is it's about rotational
velocity or rotational acceleration
there used to be
a subtopic within mechanics called
uniform
circular motion and it was one of the
things that didn't make the cut when we
went from eight topics
down to five so this is uh yes hooray
okay this
is what we're having a look at